so we're at the National Museum of
computing and what we're doing here is
building a reconstruction of Cambridge
University's first computer which is
called the electronic delays storage
automatic calculator it's the important
computer because it was the first one
that was actually built for people to
use to solve problems it helped three
groups of scientists in Cambridge win
their Nobel prizes and it was the first
machine for which there was a
programming system of the kind that a a
modern programmer would understand there
was a library of useful subroutines you
wrote in a symbolic assembly code before
that people program machines by feeding
things in through switches or just
typing in the binary code of
instructions the first machine was
scrapped to make room for its successor
physically very large a few bits and
pieces ended up in museums and that most
of it was lost and indeed very few of
the circuit diagrams and none of the
mechanical design drawings were kept all
that were retained were photographs and
high-level descriptions and so in doing
the reconstruction we've had two friends
that clear analyzed those photographs
and work back from those two the the
circuits inside the machine all the
people who worked on it had a background
on working in radar during the Second
World War and one of the key things
about radar is it transmits pulses that
bounce off an aircraft or a ship and
reads them back and of course pulses of
the basis of how a computer works in
terms of counting so they're already
from their radar work understood how to
make pulses how to amplify them how to
count them how to compare numbers
represented as sequences of pulses so
they were on the threshold of computing
and they use their expertise to build
the EDSAC machine the challenge really
has been to get back to the original
design
obviously the photographs are very
helpful but they were taken throughout
the nearly ten years that the machine
operated and they improve the design a
lot over that time so knowing which
photographs relate to the early machine
is difficult in terms of making the
circuits work this is a machine that
comes out of a more analogue view of
electronics not such the clean ones
Zero's that were used to in the
transistor world and so it's a different
way of thinking about electronic
circuits
that's certainly given us some
challenges it's really helpful that in
the volunteer team we have people who
worked on some valve computers at the
start of their careers or they worked on
valve base radar and radio systems for
the Air Force for example and so we're
tapping into what they learnt as college
students each of these units has got a
set of fingers inside if you come on
this side you can see the project is now
nearly 5 years old and the early stages
were very much a feasibility study doing
a lot of research finding out what
documentation was around and to see what
we could still obtain in the ways of it
these these valves and so forth it turns
out they are still really obtainable
because they were used in things like
military radar there's a lot of surplus
stuck around and there are companies who
still that stuff then the next challenge
was to recruit a volunteer team
particularly people who have the
expertise to be able to recreate the
designs of the circuits and we're very
fortunate we've got four or five people
with their expertise the total volunteer
team is now about 20 and the rest of the
team are very much concerned with the
the construction compared to the
pioneers we have a great advantage we
can use modern computers design EDSAC so
all this metal work is done using
computer-aided design and we send the
computer drawings to a manufacturing
company that happen to be in Cambridge
and they make all the parts to our
drawings whereas their site this and all
would have been handmade in the
university workshops similarly with the
circuits all the circuits we have and
schematics of those on the computer we
can use computer simulations to check
out the design of the circuits and in
fact check out the logic of the whole
machine so we know we're building
something that will eventually work that
wasn't a luxury that maurice wilkes and
his team had in Cambridge in 1947 when
they started many of the the basic ideas
you needed to generate pulses and so
forth have been established in the world
of radar the challenge was thinking
about how to use those to build
something that actually computes and
scaling up to a system this large there
3000 vowels in EDSAC which makes it a
very large and very complex system and
so thinking through a machine that was
that large that had lots of different
functional parts doing different jobs
that was really the challenge it was a
step up in complexity but in terms of
the basic circuit elements a radar
engineer of the 1940s would recognize
the the techniques we're using we talk
about things like cathode followers
flip-flops that's a word that still
exists in modern electronics those would
all been things that an engineer of that
time would have been aware of but we've
done so the big difference in EDSAC is a
flip-flop takes seven of these vowels
and so if you think about a microchip in
a modern computer that's got thousands
maybe millions of flip-flops in it on
EDSAC you can get about three flip-flops
on one shelf of electronics so there had
to be much more economical in their
design so it's act was very much
designed for numerical computation in
the university to help physicists and
mathematicians prior to EDSAC they had
to rely on hand calculators there were a
few manual mechanical calculators they
could use but that limited the size of
problem they could work on just because
it took so long to work on a large
matrix of numbers it's that was so much
faster about 1,500 times faster they
could work on much bigger problems and
that changed the kind of science that
could be done so one example was Radio
Astronomy what edsac allowed martin
royal to do was to put a lot of small
radio telescopes in a field collect data
from those small telescopes which are
easy to build but then with the power of
edsac had all that data together as if
it was a radio telescope the size of a
field another area where edsac helps was
what's called x-ray crystallography
which is working out the structure
inside atoms and molecules head sacks
input and output was very basic it was
five whole paper tape that was really
the established medium for inputting any
kind of data there's what was used by
the telegraph system and the telephone
systems so you fed your data in
your programming is 5 hold paper tape
and your answers came out on a online
teleprinter as a table of numbers and
because machine time was so limited and
so valuable you didn't waste time
printing pretty headings or laying
things out very neatly you kept
everything very tight and very simple
because the memory of the machine was so
small for a large calculation you might
break it into three pieces
the first piece would read the data into
the main memory then you'd load a second
program that would do the calculation on
the data in the main memory
and then you load a third program that
will pump the results out of the memory
and put them on the telly printer for
you and so they had to be quite cunning
because I though it was a huge advance
in its time it was in many ways quite a
limited machine the team who built it
realized that making it easy to program
the machine was going to be one of the
important factors influencing its
usefulness and so they very early on
established a library of standard
subroutines that packaged up
calculations for useful mathematical
functions that packaged up ways of
organizing work in the machine and doing
the input and output so typically once
you knew what your numerical problem was
you pick the right library routines you
wrote a bit of what these days we call
glue code to put those together and then
you had a working program and so none
specialists or people from other areas
like physics engineering mathematics
came to use EDSAC from the earliest days
they decided they weren't going to have
specialists edsac programmers to solve
people's problems rather than they would
teach people how to use the machine
because that was a more scalable way of
getting the computing done in terms of
running edsac the user turns up with
their paper tape and we don't quite have
it yet but there'll be a start button
there you press the start button your
paper tape reads in and hopefully the
teleprinter starts chattering the need
obviously with a valve machine like this
an experimental machine is for engineers
to maintain it and so the mathematical
laboratory has an engineering crew any
working dough I'm sure there'll be three
or four available and you rely on them
to check the machine at the start of the
day the the way the machines memory
works
it needed regular adjustment and so
there be engineers a
to help you with that they they worked
as it were a normal office dirty with
engineers in support and indeed later on
there was an operator who ran programs
for people just to get the faster flow
and work through the machine but if you
were an approved user you could work the
machine at night until it went wrong and
then you had to kind of walk away and
leave it for the engineers to fix in the
morning I'm sure there was certainly if
you taught some of the people use the
machines in those early days there are
all kinds of tales and little tricks
apparently in the early days the way you
reset the memory was by wetting your
finger and touching a terminal to earth
that part of the machine probably
something modern health and safety
wouldn't quite approve of some of these
vowels are coming out of boxes that are
labeled 1943 so they've not been used
they were made in the nowadays to having
Macintosh and Windows with everything
provided for us and layers of software
in the early days you were right near a
bear mat arm system in the first
Archimedes would run reliably well above
100 degrees C